hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my arrow midseason finale video so
many WTF twists some exciting some
really crazy so I'm gonna explain
everything just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet walk
into the arrow cave
what do you see Christmas present
haven't seen you in a long time what's
going on what have I missed so Stephen
Amell was actually talking a little bit
about this twist so I'll explain what he
said and some of the context it adds and
what the producers have said there's
been a lot of people talking about it
giving us kind of an idea for which
direction they're going to take it so
just a quick reminder that there is a
flash ring giveaway going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video make sure you enable alerts so
that you don't miss out on anything
during the break but I'll remind
everyone at the end of this what the
schedule is going to be like when
everything is coming back like flash and
all that stuff but here we go top 10 WTF
Prometheus Joker scene so this is like
right out of Suicide Squad him just
laying all those knives out just crazy
style talking to Artemis in looking at
the board of team arrow members that
he's going after so his mission is to
just make Oliver miserable but Artemis
is out for his blood like she totally
thinks that Prometheus is going to kill
him so they did a really good job in
this episode of balancing the WTF twist
like oh my god
shit's going crazy with the lighter
hopeful moments that you would expect
from a holiday episode they kind of did
that in the flash last night too so if
you look at this board like there's an X
through Quentin's face what I think that
means is is that he has just completely
messed with Quentin he hasn't killed him
but he pulled that crazy trick on him
where he gashed his arm and had the
throwing stars made him think made us
the audience think that Quentin might be
behind it all so that was just him just
completely screwing with Quentin so it
took a little while in the episode but
that's basically what it means when he
crosses out one of these team arrow
members here so they jump you know
number 9 - the big holiday party scene
where Thea and Oliver remember the
crossover last week meeting their
parents again having to lose them how it
reminded them of all the things that
they're thankful for so they try to be
kind of hopeful about it Oliver drops a
couple of Easter eggs you know my
favorite Christmas movie is die hard
which it should be die hards a great
Christmas movie but number two the
Easter egg he says he re
watched it's a wonderful life last week
which was basically the plot of arrows
100th episode and if you've never seen
that movie you should just check it out
during the Christmas period sometime
during the break just for fun but they
have a couple nights jokes just like
everybody meeting each other then being
awkward relationship comedy like olicity
getting super drunk just being really
silly like the whole conflict setting
that up with mister terrific's husband
so number eight WTF they go outside
prometheus attacks and then mr. terrific
has to explain how he didn't run in
terror when a serial killer came along
so there was kind of this running
storyline where you have prometheus
that's trying to drive everyone away
from Oliver or turn them against him in
the team doubling down no we're in the
right place we're exactly where we need
to be you know Diggle the voice of
reason but on the downside of that
mister terrific's husband does leave so
tangentially prometheus has actually
been pretty successful in his mission to
just create complete chaos within the
team so number seven they figure out
that Justin Claybourne is connected
because of the drug in mister terrific's
system they flashback to season one in a
new scene so if you guys didn't know
Justin Claybourne was only mentioned in
the pilot because he was on Oliver's
list
he was never in an actual episode of
arrow so all these flashback scenes in
this episode were brand new but they
were shot to look like they happened in
season one so like Stephen Amell was
like I really enjoyed putting the hoods
costume back on but he said that the
season 1 costume is his favorite costume
so they have this big action set piece
classic season 1 takedown you have
failed this city you know gives in to
one day but I love that they used the
big belly burger bag as the transition
just because that was a big set during
season 1 if you guys don't remember they
shot a whole bunch of scenes inside a
big belly burger restaurant but in
present day things are slowly starting
to unravel inside the group so number 6
Billy starts to figure out that mr.
terrific is working with the Green Arrow
he's a pretty good detective so he just
refuses to just let the green arrow
handle it throwing him into Prometheus's
path but he gets that text with the baby
picture out before prometheus gets him
so big surprise number 5 they analyzed
the ashes
the Prometheus was keeping and then the
picture just confirms it that it's his
son his illegitimate son but we don't
know what his name is we haven't seen
him with the mask off so we don't know
if this is a character that we've ever
seen before but it sounds like someone
that's totally new just the way they set
him up like Oliver being super
trigger-happy or aro happy however you
want to think about it in the flashbacks
biting him in the ass in the future
that's why they had that Diggle scene
you know all of her dropping bodies
gonna bite him in the ass in the future
so that is what led to the creation of
Prometheus but number four they had that
really fun Felicity flashback bit shot
to look like a season 1 Felicity Oliver
scene so this scene between them is
brand-new but like all the other
flashbacks in the episode it was made to
look like it actually happened during
season 1 so number 3 Oliver goes in for
the kill back to the factory and they
have these really cool transitions where
they flash back and forth in real time
to what Oliver was doing as he was
initially going after Claybourne with
all these bodies laid out in the exact
same way that they were in the
flashbacks and he fights his way to the
top but number two as he kills
Prometheus it turns out surprise WTF
twist that it's Billie Malone and he has
to go back and tell the team so this is
like long dark night of all those
shippers souls like you can't really
come back from this but the way they
play it is a very Captain America Civil
War typed twist where the Russos said
that when they were editing Captain
America Civil War it's all about iron
man versus Captain America who do you
think is in the right so different edits
of the film would test differently with
audiences like people would say Captain
America is right no Iron Man's right so
they edited the film down until it was
50/50 until about half of the people
thought that Iron Man was in the right
and half of the people thought that
Captain America was in the right so
that's kind of the way they played it
with Oliver killing Billy they wanted to
feel like it wasn't totally Oliver's
fault but he still killed the person
that Felicity was in love with so there
will be consequences but like even
Felicity isn't running for the door like
it doesn't seem like she's going
anywhere as much as she's in grief right
now but like Diggle said the team is not
going to split up over this we're right
where we need to be but another surprise
WTF twist
number one as he comes back to the arrow
cave seeing Laurel is alive just like
hey what's up bro Diggle is recaptured
by the police being taken back to prison
so everybody's freaking out the team is
kind of broken up a little bit although
not broken up in the way that prometheus
really wants them to break up but what
about Laurel that's really like the
thing I feel like most people are
talking about after this episode is she
really alive so Stephen Amell kind of
addressed this he said that there would
be a vetting process when they come back
in episode 10 the team will be like okay
we have to verify whether or not this is
really Laurel because they've seen all
kinds of twists they just had the
crossover episode where they were all in
a dream they've seen the Lazarus Pit
they've seen people come back from the
dead so they're going to have to verify
how Laurel is still alive is this an
alternate universe version or is she
being pulled from out of time like
somebody went back in time and brought
her forward so the other thing then a
lot of you were asking me about on
Twitter is whether or not somebody
slipped something into Oliver's drink
like Susan Williams did something to him
to make him hallucinate
but because Stephen Amell said the team
would vet her that means that the rest
of the team can see her meaning that she
is actually real she's just another
version of Laurel so my top two picks
are one Laurel pulled from another time
or two from another universe but let me
know in the comments which version of
Laurel do you think that this is and
what do you think they're going to do
with her in the back half of the season
because episode 10 is also where Talia
al Ghul debuts in the flashbacks the
Russia flashbacks so about that Oliver
said that he was trained by a woman in
Russia that's probably who Talia al Ghul
is going to be League of Assassins
training without actually being at the
League of Assassins so this is the
actress that's playing her I don't know
how many episodes that she's going to be
in or how many episodes Laurel is going
to be in but at least for episode 10 but
you can see how they're kind of taking
Diggle out of the team for the time
being so they're going to add Laurel in
for just a little while so it's going to
be a lot of fun I'm really happy with
the episode I feel like they've done a
lot better job this year so next big
question what do you guys think of this
half of the season on arrow so far and
do you think that'll be even crazier in
the back half
now that Oliver can refocus on
prometheus and we have Laurel back there
just like so much stuff going on but
that's typically what they do during
midseason finales like even on the flash
they reveal like the big mystery and
they tease what's going to be happening
in the future
likes avatar gave them that prophecy and
then showed them what was going to
happen to iris so I don't want to talk
too much about that just in case you
guys haven't seen the flash episode but
I'll add a link to that at the end of
this but what's gonna happen is this
arrow episode 10 will be January 25th
the flash will be back that week so like
all the DC shows are back that week so
I'll just remind everyone when I do
bonus videos I have a whole bunch of
flash bonus videos planned but if there
are any arrow videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments I know everybody wants to talk
about Laurel so we'll have to freak out
about that for a little while but just a
reminder that legends of tomorrow
mid-season finale is Thursday night
because the spider-man trailer is
dropping right then I'm not going to
post my legends video till Friday
morning so just a heads up about that
you know no worries I'll announce the
winner of the flash beam giveaway in
that and I will keep doing the giveaway
even during the break so no worries
about that but get hype I'll be posting
a flash bonus video tomorrow about the
Speed Force and sabotage I was going to
do that this morning but then they
dropped the spider-man teaser and
everyone was freaking out so it has been
a really awesome week for a comic book
television what you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for that
spider-man trailer video and you can
click here for my flash finale video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you